malaysia's king has declared a state of
emergency at the request of the
country's embattled prime minister
mohadeen yasin says additional powers
are needed to stop a surge in covert 19
cases
the country is reporting on average more
than 2 400 new infections every day
critics say it's an attempt by an
unstable government
to cling to power but miyadine says the
declaration is not a coup
france lawyer joins us now live from
kuala lumpur florence just explain this
to us why is it being viewed as a
potential way to hold on to power
well muir yasin the prime minister of
malaysia has been facing a leadership
challenge for months since he came to
power
unelected in a power coup that started
late february of
last year now the leadership challenge
comes not just from
politicians within the ruling alliance
but also from the opposition
opposition leader anwar ibrahim had said
last year that he had
majority support in parliament and that
he should be the next prime minister
and then he he also faced challenges
from
the um united malays national
organization that's the largest party in
his ruling coalition
now the politicians in that party feel
they've been sidelined by the muyden
administration
they've threatened to withdraw support
to force early general election
and the prime minister in his televised
address on tuesday explaining
what the state of emergency will mean
nan said
it should usher in a period of calm and
stability for the country
now in a sense there will be an end to
political
uncertainty because elections all
elections will be suspended
um until such a time that a special
committee that's going to be set up
deems it's safe to do so
but at the same time parliament and
state assembly settings will also
be suspended and that is really the
thing that concerns a lot of civil
rights activists and some analysts
um you've even got southeast asian
members of parliament issuing a
statement
saying that this feels like the median
administration the government
is trying to avoid parliamentary
oversight in requesting this
the state of emergency to be declared in
malaysia okay as you as you mentioned no
elections during this emergency period
uh no government business
um that's raising some criticism how is
that going to play out do you think
politically
well politically i think it's going to
be very hard
for opposition politicians and also
for the um members for the disgruntled
politicians in the ruling alliance to
challenge
the prime minister at this stage and the
prime minister and his televised address
also
said that anybody who doesn't cooperate
with the government
in fighting this pandemic and the state
of emergency he's made clear
is a tool for the country to fight the
pandemic
then that person um they're going to be
punished
because that's in that's essentially
going against the government
so in a way i think analysts will say
that he has
in a way been able to buy himself some
time at least
until the end of the emergency which for
this for
which as we know which what we know now
is going to go on until the first of
august
or possibly earlier if um the number of
coronavirus cases
in malaysia start to drop okay think of
that france lloyd there live from kuala
lumpur